STOP RIGHT WHAT YOU ARE DOING !
I need you to do something for me
Alright
I can't be here
JUST WHAT EVER YOU DO
DON'T
TELL
MARZIA !!!
oooooooh
OoooOOOhhh
OOOOH
ooooooh
OH ME OH MA POTATOE SALAD Pie
Okay
So i get to pick
which girl i want to hire for my cam studio
*perverted tounge movement*
Now i don't know what a cam studio is
but I'm gonna go with ma...
...ma girl
Tiffey ( Tiffany )
Tip tita Tip
Okay
So we got Tiffany
MUAH
finest quality of fresh meat
So we put her in the cam studio over here...
...and she will start making us money...
...by skyping to people
NOTHING WEIRD !!!
Why does...
...why does this studio look like Jacksepticeye ?
Jacksepticeye : TOP OF THE MORNING TO YOU LADDIES MY NAME IS JACKSEPTICEYE
So she's making us money...
5 bucks
Tiffey, that's not that much
what we also have to do, is we have to get a photo shoot
so we get more fans
see that gave us...
5 fans
alright, so now...
we can buy, so we can have two girls at once
Aight who should we go with Nikki?
Na...
Nadia
or Zoey
what the fuck happened Zoey?
this is not The Fifth Element Zoey get the fuck out
we're going with Nadia, she might be a man...
but at least she doesn't look like a fuckin Tumblr girl
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOH
oooouuuhhh
urgh, is it hot in here?
am I sweating?
alright lets get another girl
we got Sarah
she's got a...
THICK ESS
urghh
we got Audrey
she's a teen
we got Lailani, she's Asian
Ouhhhh
How-how houler louer
why am I so into this game?
this is literally a cookie clicker
but I'm so into it
aight so we can look at our fans
our fans are into THICK ASS
I can respect that
alright I think we are going to grow the THICK ESS
girl in game: did I do good?
Pewds : Did i do gooOOoOoood? ( Pewds moan while makin love )
Sexy Pewds: yes you did darling
Sarah...
is an unbearable weeaboo who thinks she's Japanese and calls herself " Suki"...
she's the worst, but she's still kinda hot in a weird way
ok we're gonna have to recruit someone new
THICK ASS
We're gonna have to go with the THICK ASS
WE'RE NICHING IN THICK ASS - Pewdiepie2016 -
alright ... I am ... I hate to do this
but we're gonna have to replace our main bitch
TIFFEY
We're go ... we're the THICK ASS STUDIO
she pulls in so many fans
that fuckin kawaii...
kawaii girl man
yes I am having the time of my Life  SHUT THE FUCK UuuUUUuuP
get a THICK ASS!
then we can talk Tiffey
Tiffany: Sure thing
if i go to heaven, I want ... I want this game to be my life
alright, what are our fans into ?
they LOVE thick ASS
we're gonna be rich
we're gonna be RICH !
so now we can advertise our cam studio
Cake farting ...
DON'T look up cake farts
Its not worth it
ey listen we have THICK ASSES ofcourse we've gotta fart on cakes
what the fuck kind of business do you think we're running here?
if you don't do cake farting ...
YOU'RE OUT OF THE GAME !!!
I'm really glad I'm watching this screen and not the cam studio screen
thats ... thats ... what I would of ... I prefer this way thank you, thank you very much I ...
game character: my pleasure~
Pewds: Yep
we can buy butt plug!
Alright, who should have the butt plug?
THIS IS THE BEST GAME OF ALL TIME
yeah, the ... the weeaboo gets the butt plug
WoooooOOOOHooo
whoever...
whoever came up with the idea of this game is a goddamn genius
ok now we gat L ... OOH LILLIAN I LOVE HER
wait so I can send my girls to a ...
sleazy motel
WOOOW
good job game
you continue to amaze me
we can have cake farts.
alright let's get the cake farts
ooh let's make this Latina girl ...
get some cake farts
girl in game: awesome!
Pewds: She likes it
lets invest in cake-farting
DON'T TELL MARZIA FOR THE LOVE OF GOD ABOUT CAKE FARTS !
*INHALES* JESSIEEE!!!
OUUUHHHHHHH!!!
YEAAAAAAAAAHHHH!!!
Oh my god!
YESSS
(Demented sound)
alright now ...Now let's promo...
FORBIDDEN CAVERN ANAL
Holy shit she make alot of money on this sleazy hotel
Nadia you're going again
yep
she's Russian she's okay with it
She's got gonorrhea
Look at me
I'm a mess
what's wrong with me?
I have a girl friend
KEEP CLICKING!
I can't click fast enough!
I can't click fest enough !!
I can't believe the most annoying fuckin girl in the whole world...
got the most fans
I'm so fuckin into this game it's pathetic but I love it
Oooh we got RENEE !
She's got a THICK ASS !
what did she say ?
KOALA
girl in game: KOALA
God I'm so tired of clickiiiiing!!!
this game is horible and sexist and i hate it
it's ruin my life
I'm out
what happened?
WHAT?!!
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?!!
that just RANDOMLY HAPPENED!!!
I AM NOT SOME FUCKIN LEVEL A GRADE PIMP!!!
WHAT???!!
Eyyyy it's okay
* clapshands*
It's okay i got to see Tiffey
Best ...  best game!!!
I feel like this game...
has changed me!
this is not who I am...
Ah, Who Am I kidding?
MAKE SURE YOUR ASS IS WAXED NEXT TIME TIFFANY!!!